[Music]
now i'm going to revisit each one
demonstrate it slowly and provide an
additional note regarding the
performance aspect of it
[Music]
for this one i would focus on connecting
all of the notes to bring out this
legato quality
as opposed to something more detached or
pointy
just something much more fluid
as opposed to
in a previous video i played this phrase
so this exercise
is basically the counterpoint to the
right hand version
[Music]
for this one i would focus on bringing
out the lilting quality
by sort of sitting on the larger beads
[Music]
both with the left hand and the right
hand
as opposed to playing all of this evenly
[Music]
for this one the tempo is very important
it shouldn't be played too fast or too
slow because for example if you play too
fast
or too slow
you lose a very important rhythmic
quality that i'm going after which is
the bottom notes
against the top notes
[Music]
especially if you play it too fast i
think the ears focus on the top notes
[Music]
and it just sounds a little plain so
also that is why i'm playing the right
hand
notes together with the bottom notes
to bring out that quality as opposed to
this
[Music]
for this one i think it's quite easy to
get very tense so what i like to do is
focus on this circular motion happening
when
you're turning around on the bottom
notes
it's basically this scoop
where your wrist and your elbow is
following this circular motion going
from the bottom
around to the top
of course this is very exaggerated
but a little bit of this motion
[Music]
like the first exercise this one was
written as a counterpoint to the right
hand version
[Music]
even though this is how i wrote it i
actually don't like playing it together
like this not only because it's very
hard but it ends up sounding very muddy
it's hard enough to keep it clear with
just the
left hand
also on that note i think there is a bit
of a pedaling issue that is worth noting
these descending notes here
i do this sort of half petal where i'm
still changing every five notes
here
and here
and here
otherwise it sounds like this
which is something that ends up
happening anyway sometimes
but i think the half pedal helps that is
all for this video i hope you found that
useful thank you to all of my supporters
on patreon over there i'll be uploading
an additional video regarding these
exercises i'll be sharing intermediate
versions of each one of them and also
just more notes on how to practice them
so
again thank you so much and i will see
you very soon bye